welcome to america's favorite answer in
question game
jeopardy we have become so ingrained
in american and canadian culture that
we are not so much a television
entertainment program as part of the
family
and having hosted the show since 1984
alex himself
was a part of that family too the
category as you know is holidays
e.t first visited the set of jeopardy
way back in 1986.
we consider ourselves to be the
rolls-royce of game shows if you want to
test your intellectual skills
but before the northern ontario born
native found success on the small screen
he had
very different plans at one point you
were thinking of becoming a priest is
that true yes but that
i didn't think about that for too long i
had a better shot at being a
telemarketer for hockey equipment but i
didn't pursue that either
and i'm glad i went into television
jeopardy fans were glad too
and we're guessing so are comedians and
in last place
tony bennett whose score is so low
it can't be represented by a real number
i don't mind being made fun of you can
poke fun at me
i just get a great kick out of it you
dig it yeah it's
you've arrived when that happens alex
who has two adult children with his wife
jean never seemed to take himself too
seriously you have that smart thing
a lot of women like that smart thing
well i hope there's more to me than just
my brain
and even when we spoke to him after the
first of two of his mild heart attacks
he was in a joking mood this man looks
amazing how do you do it
what's your secret heavy drugs heavy
drugs
even when it came to his health alex's
humor honesty and positivity shone
through
even as he updated fans at his brain
surgery which he called
a slight medical problem the prognosis
is excellent
and i expect to be back in the studio
taping more jeopardy programs
very very soon but never was his
optimism and dry wit more apparent
than when he announced his stage 4
pancreatic cancer diagnosis
i plan to beat the low survival rate
statistics for this disease
truth told i have to because under the
terms of my contract
i have to host jeopardy for three more
years
a week later alex had another message
this one solemn
the beloved host humbly showing
appreciation for his supportive fans
i am thankful for the kind words the
prayers
and the advice you have offered and i'm
extremely touched by the
warmth you have expressed in your
comments to me
i'm a lucky guy